hey everyone it's my vatos and welcome
to the order flows market analysis for
Thursday September 14 2017 the Dow
closed at another record he was up 0.2
percent to 22 203 I believe but the big
news was after the market closed there
was an another missile launch by North
Korea now the markets did sell-off but
you know it's important to know traders
aren't getting as excited I hate to use
the term excited but you know that
they're not reacting the way they were
you know reacting a few weeks ago
thinking we're on the brink of war I
mean consider the Japanese and it's a
very very liquid contract and you know
people view the yen as a as a safe haven
in times of you know geopolitical or
financial stress so an especially that's
a contract that's going to be very
sensitive to any any reaction to North
Korea so what happened is the market
soared currency soared abouts about a
half a percent against the dollar within
a minute of the old news coming out that
North Korea had launched another missile
towards Japan but with three minutes
later two-thirds of that advanced
advance had evaporated and you know
later a couple hours later it was barely
unchanged from where closed during New
York session so you know the people that
are reacting to these this news are the
retail traders you know the dealers and
you know the banks and the bank traders
the Forex deal you know that they're
sort of this guy's a discounting it but
you know they're they are not reacting
the way they were reacting a few weeks
ago you know because they they realize
what North Korea is doing that you know
it's we're not going to be sitting on a
World War 3 just yet thank goodness so
anyway a brief disclaimer before we get
started this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation a buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures train
contain substantial risk and it's not
for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past reports it's not necessarily
indicative of future results tools we
use in this presentation are the order
flow trader the Delta scalper and the
price rejecter
now you know these indicators these all
run on ninjatrader they were on
ninjatrader seven NinjaTrader eight you
know yesterday I posted a I posted a
video on ninjatrader eight and you know
as luck would have it bad luck would
have it I guess is more of the
descriptive term in typical NinjaTrader
fashion I got an after I you know
installed everything on my computer you
know Microsoft excited hey you know what
we want to do an upgrade of you know
whatever software was sitting on my
since my computer so you know I went in
there and didn't you know a series of
Windows upgrades and of course that is
giving me a pain in the butt with
NinjaTrader so you know it's unfortunate
I did get in there yesterday as I was
trying to launch a NinjaTrader
eight-minute launch it worked and what
it was darn slow then you know in the
end I just I just sort of gave up and
went back to NinjaTrader seven I just
want to get you uh get him picture of
this this error here this it's one I
haven't seen before my name it work it
out here unable to connect the database
the CRT binary present in application
bin folder is not signed and can be a
potential security risk although I did
add another indicator another soft
another vendors indicator on there then
I you know had like a look at some times
and you know I honestly since I added
that that's when that happened but so I
might have to just take that one out and
give it a try so today's presentation
will be on ninjatrader seven until I
could be sure I got everything really
worked out now okay so that you know
again I was talking about Japanese yen
now if you're trading your currencies
are GME currencies rather you should be
in the December contract I haven't
changed you know the volume now is is
definitely in the the December it
switched uh any no volume and open
interest in open interest is really what
you got to watch and was switching on
Wednesday but the volume in the futures
were still in the December I show you
the September
yesterday but you know just really quick
I'll show you the yen this is what
happened in the end so he closed you
know here at was at ninety seventy boom
missile comes missile launch here we
shoot up to 91 yeah you know ninety 127
then we just give it all back really
quick you know these are yeah this
little retail traders you know this is
how they they lose money you know they
react to these things rather than you
know analyze what's what's going on
North Korea launched the missile we
better just pile into the end and you
can see right now you know where are we
trading what time is it it's it's it's
1:15 Chicago time and look we're trading
we're trading well below yesterday's
close 90 45 so not only did we give it
back to me
right after that move but we've just
been trading down down down now speaking
of the end there were some interesting
order flow analysis in the end yesterday
let me get my my yen chart up flip it
was in the end okay so early morning not
early morning but short eight o'clock
you have a new high here you got your
ratio 0.6 0 you've got a divergence got
the negative Delta you got the Delta
scalper you got point control right up
here near the high now this is a set up
and I talked about I even call it a
setup this is what's the proper term
that I hate to use the term set up but
this appears in the market almost every
day not necessarily this market you know
maybe in the Japanese yen today British
Pound your currency you know the next
day it's and it's still in some of these
markets where not everything I mean it's
nice to see them in every single market
every day but sometimes they don't
appear in a market for you know a day or
so but that's just the market you know
you don't get the textbook examples
every day but this is the beautiful one
here this is at 9:00 sorry 755 you got
everything lining up here the only thing
you don't have is a bunch of selling
imbalances in this bar you know a nice
stacked and balanced would make it look
a lot nicer but you're coming up into
this high you got some relatively small
Delta's 1225 829 boom you hit the new
high strong selling minus 116 you still
got selling in the next bar minus 65 you
know I'd love to
see a stronger negative Delta honestly
here but you know markets moving pretty
quick so there's not a lot of volume
going through you know and we're just
heading down down down
you know from at this point it's 90 60
and you know he's you know just keep
trading down down down here you got the
Delta scalper giving you a buy back here
at 38 so from 60 down to 40 then you
just sort of go sideways you hit this
low down here at 8:30 and you start
rolling up you know this yeah there's a
reason in here to be buying here you
know you got that imbalance point of
control towards the bottom but you know
I like clearer signals clearer signs
here you have the price rejector giving
you a sell signal you know we had just
rallied up from this low coming back up
here to the 50 ere you get up to 49 you
seen some signs of price rejection which
is bearish and what happens is we can't
get past this you know we come back up
within a tick of it here you got the
single print and then you just sort of
hang around you test it again got
another three Lots traded there here you
had the Delta scalper giving you a buy
okay but then you run up into price
rejection so you know if this one would
have stopped you out honestly I don't
think you would it be enough time for
you to to get out of this you know
before it stops you out because you know
your stop would just be below this area
here then what do you got you got Delta
scalper giving you a sell you sitting
here at 90 40 and boom what happens is
we we sell-off down into the 1930s we
get down here you know by this time
right you're trading 90 34 you know 35
in here so you know your short from 40
this trades in half tick so it's
actually you know 440 down to 35 is 10
ticks you know you get this this was
interesting you got this stack selling
and balance here but then you run into
this bar with point of control right on
the bottom which was a bullish sign you
also have a bullish ratio and what
happens is the market shoots right back
up now you know I have talked about when
you see stacked imbalances which you
know in this case it's a stacked selling
and balance but you come right back with
a bullish ratio here in the next bar
after your stacked imbalance it's not
going to be very effective and you can
see it traded
back up here and then sold off but you
know by this point here the whole stack
selling imbalances is falling apart the
whole argument for you're looking at
bullish ratio bullish ratio you
shouldn't be long still or sorry short
up here taking all that heat yeah you
can get back in down here you know
you've got the bearish ratio here you
got the price rejecter you got the
single print and you start to sell off
but when you have a stacks on a balance
and you come right back with us with a
bullish ratio in the next bar it's not
going to be very effective as a trade
just as if you had to stack buying and
balance and you had a bearish ratio in
the next part it's also not going to be
very encouraging as a trade so you sell
off from this price rejector down here
to this price rejecter 9030 he got some
areas in here to be looking to be buying
around 34 and what happens boom I mean
just shoot straight up up up up here
this is what I'm talking about
okay so you know if you go up from 30 up
to 50 okay and you know so that's
another 20 ticks there with the price
rejecter but look at this what do you
have here you have stack buying and
balance followed by a stack selling a
balance okay but more importantly what
do you got you've got a stack buying in
balance the next bar you've got the
bearish ratio just as you know just here
right what I was explaining I think it
was what was it here you have the stacks
on a balance and you got the bullish
ratio right here here you have the
opposite you have the stack mine and
balance with the bearish ratio and what
happens nothing it just sort of goes
sideways and eventually sells off and
again it would have stopped you out but
you can recognize that it's happening in
here even before you see the stack
selling a balance obviously having a
stack behind imbalance followed by a
stack selling a balance it is not a good
thing if you're long if the best thing
to do is go with the direction of the
next selling the next stacked imbalance
in this case be short or do nothing you
know get out and take your take your
loss and wait for something else I'll
say I do find these to be you know these
overlapping imbalances to be quite nice
trade setups you know you do come back
up here before you sell off wasn't
really the greatest trading opportunity
but then you know you're coming in to
two o'clock and you know that was it I
don't want to talk about after three
o'clock in the end really
after 2 o'clock you shouldn't really be
trading the currencies that's when you
know the trading books are closed at the
bank so you know liquidity does get a
little bit less just really quick this
is the what is this this is the e minis
I just want to show you the reaction to
the Korean missile launch earlier in the
day at 6 in the morning and I sell here
these cells failed but late in the day
again I'm not one that's gonna have the
Kate say hey you get short ten minutes
before the clothes 20 minutes before the
clothes and hold it into the next
session but this is what happened to the
market look at it it reopened we sold
off from the what is that 94 all the way
down to 88 now again it looks dramatic
on this chart I mean it's it's like
almost you know yesterday's range pretty
much you know this is yesterday's high
as 96 yesterday's Lowe's was at 87 and a
half and we just sold off immediately
from 94 down to 87 more or less 87 a
quarter think it was you know been in
the first ten minutes first five minutes
actually so that's our low and you know
we've just been creeping back up and
where we now at you know before the
European open is you know 91 75 so you
know we've we've rejected that sell-off
you know and then the markets recovered
you know I always say recover obviously
if we were trading that but new highs
and I'd say we fully recovered but it's
you know it's it's it's it got it back
it you know the move is wasn't as I say
the market is not reacting you know
they're calling I guess I guess you
would say the markets calling Kim's
bluff so to speak okay so anyway let's
take a look at one or two other markets
really quick give me a sec okay just
really quick in the euro currency I
wanted to show you this this is what I
call the point of control on the extreme
here it's on the top of the bar you know
you got the bearish ratio which is also
nice next bar you got the Delta scalper
kicking in so you know it's changing you
know selling is starting to come in here
so you know up here you have some
resistance now again you know this is
the September contract December again
this is our
you had some numbers coming out early so
the markets moving pretty quick but
still you know when you get bars like
this watch it and watch how the market
reacts to it you know what do we do it
you know we're trading the next bar at
you know three down in here in this bar
and you sell off from Oh three all the
way down here and to where you got the
next Delta scalper by around you know
the ninety one area so that's again the
trade scene that's about 20 ticks right
there trades in half ticks so that was a
nice trade alright so this is the bonds
this morning here so again again you had
numbers coming out at 7:30 I don't you
know very quiet morning coming into the
numbers so you know after the number
again I can say yeah you have the price
rejecter here right on the low giving
you buy you've got a divergence you got
a ratio on the next bar and the market
rallies up into the high but again you
know that's I could easily say that
couldn't claim that say hey look I'm a
genius but I don't trade you know with
around these numbers you know I give it
the market a chance to relax so from
7:30 to 7:35 you know I signals that I
see are generally with the grain of salt
however later after we hit this high you
get the Delta scalper up here giving you
a sell but look what you got here you
have a delta now you have a point of
control on the extreme it's on the
bottom of the green bar you don't have a
bullish ratio as well so even though you
got to delta scupper giving you a
bearish sign it comes right back with a
bullish sign you hit your new high up
here this actually is the Balto's you
turn it's hard to see that arrow there
then the next bar Delta scalper okay so
you're at your high def discover so even
if you took this trade here earlier
you got stopped out or maybe you read
what was happening in here and you got
out at a small loss before it stops you
out again you got your second chance in
here and another trading opportunity you
don't give up that just because it you
know you took a loss don't say ah
Trading sucks you know I mean it's it's
a process right you're gonna have
winners you're gonna have losers you got
to keep going you know keep keep
plugging away at it and then the next
trade you know you're talking ten
minutes later twelve minutes later
this is 749 this is 801 you know if you
be getting short here around 155 even
you know it makes a nice move makes a
nice move all the way down into you know
154 24 area before
just sort of stables stabilizers right
around the unchanged level here or the
opening price rather at at 29 you know
the other nice thing was up here on this
on this high you know I like how you get
shifts in Delta like this you know and
from a nice strong positive to a neutral
one to a strong negative I always treat
that as a nice sign you know even in
here that's why I was sort of looking
for the bit of the sell-off but you know
this bar here earlier it's a it's in
doji it's actually kind of a bearish bar
Candlestick wise and Delta wise I mean
it was positive fourteen seventy ended
up only at 270 but at no point did ever
get negative then you had the strong
selling in here this was just a false
start it was just a little bit of buying
left over then the market popped up you
know then it just sort of went hung
around literally hung around this level
then you know the rest of this session
pretty much we did get a bit of a pop up
you know during the asian session but
not much I mean usually you'd see a
bigger jump in the bonds but you didn't
see it today with the Korean missile
launch
alright so SP is really quick very quiet
morning coming into the US hours you
know you had a high of 94 and
three-quarters your low was like 91 and
three quarters so about a three-point
range as you're coming into the New York
session you know we start trending a bit
lower the number came out we hit some
new lows down here you do have
divergence but you got it with a bearish
ratio then the bullish ratio and of
course then the market rallies huh you
know it's just unfortunate that you had
this this one bar here you know if you
could slide this bar here you would you
know then you could claim any ratio and
divergence but you know having this one
bar in between doesn't doesn't help the
argument you got up here just for nine
o'clock you got the price rejecter and
Delta scalper unfortunately the market
just went sideways on you that didn't
work out I said is at this point you
know your high is still 94 and
three-quarters your low is 87 and a half
so still a tight range but if you're
getting up here near the high you know
I'm I'm curious to see if we could break
out and you know you start getting the
price rejecter here you don't sell off
still that positive Delta still got
positive Delta here you know with
getting short on something I also
ideally an insert and search ideally I'd
like to see negative Delta if I'm really
looking to get short like here you got
the price rejector and Delta scalper you
got negative Delta here you got positive
Delta a positive Delta with price
rejector if I'm looking for price to be
rejected I want to see selling come in
and I'm gonna be looking at the Delta
for the confirmation but anyway you get
up here to this new high at 10 o'clock
you got your divergence no ratio point
controlled near the top you got your
racial in the next bar and then you can
see did the market sell-off not really
it's just one sideways unfortunately it
was a quiet day I mean what can you do
you know if you're getting short
somewhere here so you can short it
ninety four and a half you know what it
do it sold off to two and three quarters
eventually you know it got down to
almost two two and a half but again by
that time you know from ten o'clock
until one o'clock honestly if I'm short
here at ten forty one and it's 11:40 and
it's just sort of hanging around here I
just you know rather take whatever I can
get out of the trade and and be done
with it it's a bit quiet than the
obviously later in the session the
market sold off when it reopened with on
the Korean stuff just really quick you
know it's just easier to show you on
this chart this is a bar chart of the
British Pound eight range in the Delta
scalper this morning you know there was
some nice signals you know just I don't
wanna make it that's too hard to see but
you know just go back here so you know
first signal you gotta buy down here and
then a cell that fails another cell that
fails another nice buy hear from you
know what is that the thirty area all
the way up to the wrong close to the
this area up here 133 even rather up to
130 330 it it looks small looks like a
small move but is actually a it's
actually a quite a nice move from here
up to here because you know the British
Pound had a nice a nice trading range
yesterday so you know 133 in this area
up to 133 30 you got a cell here did
sell off a little bit for it came back
and sort of took you out then here you
got a nice little cell again from 50
gotta lay down to 30
another
another nice little cell here a nice buy
here you know another nice buy here and
going into the close so that's the that
was the Delta scalper again it's not an
eight range chart in the British Pound
so again you know if you're still if you
haven't updated your charge for the
currencies definitely update them today
so thanks for watching this and you
don't have a great day and hopefully I
get my MTA issue resolved I think I got
a I know what I got to do I've got
another build for order flows and I just
gotta make sure I got the right version
of NinjaTrader a tie my system so anyway
guys have a great day and I'll catch you
later bye bye